foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today
is SCP 2099.
object class
Euclid
special containment procedures
objects composing scp-2099 are kept in
place at the recovery site all
Communications phone lines Lan Etc have
been severed all wireless devices have
been found and destroyed the previous
sentence was stricken from the document
the addendum 2099 for
the warehouse above the recovery site is
currently owned and operated by Smith
Campbell publishing LLC a front that
distributes disinformation material any
instances of
scp-2099-b Taken off-site are to be
disguised as shipments of printed
materials
the entrance to the recovery site is
protected by a steel door that requires
Personnel on both sides to open it will
be kept closed whenever not in use
Personnel will monitor all active
peripherals under the control of
scp-2099-a any peripherals Beyond those
permitted are to be reported at once and
destroyed
description
scp-2099 is the brain of Jeremy Valdez
and all Associated machinery and
equipment contained in place at the
recovery location
scp-2099 was found under a derelict
Warehouse in Detroit Michigan in 2003
after Urban explorers posted pictures
online the original account was deleted
and amnestics administered but some
images of scp-2099 still exist online
with different contexts given this is
considered to be a low risk to
containment
the recovery site is a series of 13
underground structures ranging from
three by three by two meters to 30 by 20
by 10 meters some act as storage units
containing shelves holding thousands of
mechanical and electronic devices and
parts others are largely open intended
for use in testing one contains mostly
heavy machinery believed to have been
used in Excavating the recovery site
every room has hundreds to thousands of
pieces of paper on which notes are
written these are in fragmentary
shorthand a row of numbers and letters
at the top of each sheet appears to act
as a reference to the contents of each
sheet although the precise meaning has
not been decoded
valdez's brain Hereafter referred to as
scp-2099-a is kept in a jar filled with
water mixed with electrolytes sugars
green food coloring and artificial
flavoring how this keeps scp-2099-a
alive or if it even plays any role
Beyond aesthetic is unknown at this time
scp-2099-a has been largely Cooperative
with Foundation Personnel although its
answers have been of limited usefulness
instances of scp-2099-b are devices
built by
scp-2099-a both before and after its
present condition these machines are
built from a number of materials
virtually all of them appear to be
highly technologically advanced but
should not function based on current
understanding of science based on power
draws material limitations or violations
of constants such as the speed of light
several are referred to as peripherals
devices directly under the control of
scp-2099-a these are used by
scp-2099-a to interact with its
environment most of these were destroyed
during recovery five are currently
active contingent on
scp-2099-a's continued cooperation these
range from mechanical hands to a
humanoid robot dressed as a butler these
are used primarily to find and bring
notes to scp-2099-a
examples of scp-2099-b
a pistol that fires out high intensity
X-rays and is powered by two double-a
batteries and focused by a common quartz
crystal
a six meter tall humanoid robot made
primarily of chrome and steel tensile
strength of materials involved should
not be capable of supporting its weight
a cannon that fires sabots that release
human-sized robots armed with swords and
metal nunchucks notably the volume of
the sabots is not large enough to fit
the robots
a bin labeled cyborg parts inside were a
number of artificial limbs sensory
organs and other body parts none of them
have been attached so it is unknown
whether or not they would be functional
no means of interacting with the nervous
system could be found on any of these
parts
a large vehicle with a mounted drill and
Claws capable of tunneling through solid
rock and earth materials so displaced
disappears leaving empty tunnels
a rocket-based spacecraft sediment stuck
to the skids matches samples taken from
the Moon there is no plausible means by
which it could have exited the recovery
site
a force field generator it cannot be
examined at this time as
scp-2099-a has forgotten how to
disengage the device
a large generator with anti-gravity
written on the side anti has been
crossed out in red paint when engaged
all nearby objects weigh twice what they
normally would in Earth gravity
a computer system running an apparently
complete simulation down to individual
grains of sand of an alien solar system
it performs with two gigabytes of
available disk space
713 laser guns and a bin labeled
713 different laser guns
electricity is supplied by a number of
interconnected power strips following
the power strips ultimately leads to a
final power strip plugged into itself
unplugging it removes power from the
entire facility
interview log scp-2099 A1
who are you I am the profound Professor
V the genius who invented the quantum
pistol the rocket to Sagittarius the
window to other worlds my name is Jeremy
Valdez
Jeremy
there was another Jeremy I met once well
Lance buddy the one stuck in my mind
cleverman a Salesman can't trust them an
inch if you give them a mile but that
wasn't me how did you build this
facility oh I dug it all out tricky bit
was the supports used solid valdezium to
hold it up that's my own invention named
trademarked button pending
unless I forgot to send the application
how do your inventions work I'm a genius
have I mentioned that I'm sure I have
it's in my notes yes yes you've read
them haven't you I left them simply
everywhere you can't miss them
when did you start inventing things
let's see let's
it 93 94
I'd forget my head if it wasn't
carefully labeled in the closet no wait
that's not the note I was looking for ah
yeah history good Evans 91 has it been
that long how long has it been
what's the date never mind anyway I
started having ideas one day just ideas
pouring in from everywhere can hardly
look at a shovel without getting an idea
for a digging machine or a computer
without seeing if it dreams of shape
oh I could use lasers for a drill take a
note I've always been a tinkerer ever
since I was a boy had model rockets and
ray guns and all sorts of toys like that
get them from stores or mail order or
wherever I could as
scp-2099-a spoke peripherals brought
notes to its tank and wrote down further
notes apparently based on the
conversation
how is this facility powered oh you just
plug things in simple as anything
ultimately draws from the Aether they
say there's no such thing but you just
have to know where to look it's all
under that Quantum stuff
or was it in the imaginary numbers
this somewhere like that I'd have to
look at my note
we've had difficulties in reading your
notes oh well that's easy enough you
just need to know how things are broken
out there's a note about that somewhere
earn notes seem
incomplete well that's a Pity I tried to
keep it all together but things get put
here and there can't do a thing without
my notes let me check my notes yes can't
do a thing without them right here
you'll argue with that it's in my notes
interview log scp-2099 A7
in your inventions oh a bit of this bit
of that I make things for people
sometimes for sale sometimes barter
not so honest work before I got to that
point of course worked for a pro lab
back in the day and did r d for a
manufacturing Club made smoke alarms or
toys of some such hard keeping all
straight these days do you have any
outstanding orders
not at the moment but there's always new
businesses just around the corner people
need things built sound guns hypnosis
lenses rocket skis night vision goggles
that even work when there's no light
whatsoever
a little pedestrian but it pays the
bills haven't heard much lately but I'm
sure they'll be in touch soon
interview log scp-2099 a19
are you aware of your current condition
look brilliant handsome brain in a jar
at an escape my notice
how are you still alive
good diet and exercise Healthy Living oh
and the electrolytes it's in my notes
somewhere the whole process never will
look at mashed potatoes the same way
I'll tell you that
do any of your family or friends know
about your condition
no not really family was never close but
most of my friends are online these days
on the internet nobody knows you're a
brain in a jar or a or one of them
you've heard the joke I'm sure how did
it happen
you know I'm not entirely sure anymore I
don't think I was dying or anything no
my my body's still perfectly viable
I can remember where I put him all
I remember why I did it or quite when
I'm sure it seemed like a good idea at
the time usually does
somehow didn't work out quite how I
thought
I I don't think or maybe addictive
anyway I get by
samples of notes found within the
discovery site
went via WB Mark II to consult with hgw
on temp wobble suggested to talk to EB
for flux correction
rt304 failure due to insufficient
copyright formula needs work
MK and LS say SF may know glorious V
skink protocol in effect on Sixth Day
Cascade failure in Nuke gen nearly
destroyed facility also self much of n a
check notes twice
I am Jack's lack of OSHA compliance
how long have brain been in jar must
investigate later busy now
ehp28c sent payment for project
20083 despite dissatisfaction no hard
feelings
snails will not undergo cold fusion
despite best efforts possibly weaponized
SF closing sending backups to station
version 2 before wet wear checked
I see secret agent people
addendum 2099 1. since recovery a number
of scp-2099-b objects have been
discovered in the hands of others
whether these are objects previously
made and sold by
scp-2099-a or if there is another source
has not been established to any degree
of certainty
addendum 2099 too
scp-2099-a has at times made references
to locations where it is operated or
used as training points when dealing in
examples of
scp-2099-b cscp 2099 recovery logs for
further information
addendum 2099 4.
scp-2099-a made a reference to the
shenzhou 9 mission in 2012 when asked
how it learned of this it revealed an
active internet connection via v-wave
Universal ansible when asked where the
device was located it could only
remember that it was somewhere on the
shelves and suggested it be found by
Valdez wave detection to date the device
still has not been found analysis of
Internet accounts now known to be
associated with
scp-2099-a have shown no revelation of
protected information however recovery
and dismantling of this device is to be
considered a priority objective for
staff assigned to scp-2099
addendum 2099 5. while
scp-2099-a's ansible remains hidden it
can be disrupted via bursts of microwave
radiation however this also renders
scp-2099-a incapable of speech and may
interfere with its life support given
that it is currently the only method of
recovering
scp-2099-b instances outside of
foundation control this will only be
used in emergency situations
scp-2099 recovery logs
location former home previously owned by
scp-2099-a according to tax records
prompting statement from
scp-2099-a oh that old place yes very
nice neighborhood but the HOA had
ridiculous rules about spaceships and
they didn't allow me to have any
dinosaurs what kind of totalitarian
Wasteland doesn't allow dinosaurs
especially robot ones
but the park was nice I used to feed
pigeons I think I may have left some
things there up in the attic crawl space
might still be there
recovery while the current owners were
on vacation in Hawaii recovery agents
searched the home eventually finding an
old notebook covered in scribbles of
rocket ships and space aliens
response oh my drawings I used to
scribble those down in school drove my
teachers crazy but what could they say
straight A student got my report cards
somewhere on the shelves most likely
I'll check my notes
location alley in Boston Massachusetts
prompting statement from
scp-2099-a I certainly hope M.A got her
package I left it in the usual place
right when it was done but I never heard
back from her maybe you gentleman could
take a look since I'm short a couple of
legs at the moment
recovery the field team went to the
location described though it was
assessed that they would be unlikely to
find anything in the intervening time
however shortly after beginning their
search they were attacked by a chaos
Insurgency field team which had
apparently set up a watch for future
drop-offs in the location the chaos
Insurgency team was apparently not
expecting armed resistance and
Foundation casualties were kept to a
minimum several enemy combatants were
detained and two weaponized anomalies
secured
response those people eh have had some
run-ins with them before nasty customers
saw them one or two things and then they
tried to get all my toys without paying
for them didn't know they were watching
Boston well I'm glad you dealt with them
hopefully they didn't give ma any
trouble
location Soup Kitchen in Seattle
Washington where ports of unusually
sized foodstuffs had been reported
prompting statement from scp-2099-a
none
recovery
the field team secured the location
finding a large Booth labeled v-ray
enlarger which employees had been using
to increase portions of food handed out
to the local homeless interviewed
employees stated it had been brought in
by operatives of the Mana charitable
Foundation two weeks earlier
response oh the enlarger I think I
remember that one did I sell it to them
well I must have they probably just got
around to using it now
I haven't had much business with them in
a while
location former missile silo in Southern
Idaho records indicate that it was never
sold by the US government
prompting statement from
scp-2099-a oh I spent some time in the
midwest I was is there a classier word
than squatting one moment ah here we go
habitating in one of those old missile
silos
they weren't using it so I just moved in
turned on the lights more of a summer
home than anything I don't think I took
the trash out before I left would your
gents be so kind
recovery the field team found the silo
sealed within several combination locks
which were opened with codes provided by
scp-2099-a inside were three desiccated
human bodies a taxidermied mammoth
americanum and a gorilla in some form of
suspended animation DNA testing showed
that the human bodies all belonged to
scp-2099-a a partial address and key
were found at the bottom of the desk
drawer response oh well I was going
through a cloning phase too much
Jurassic Park not enough meeting girls
though the mosquito trick doesn't work
if you get anything you just get
mosquitoes notably a dress and key were
not brought to
scp-2099-a's attention
location Warehouse in Puebla Mexico
having been traced to a dark net site
titled V2 Enterprises several products
were determined to have anomalous
properties similar to instances of
scp-2099 B
prompting statement from scp-2099-a
none recovery workers in the warehouse
were in the process of moving all
inventory through a device that was
apparently capable of teleportation or
disintegration teleportation assessed to
be more likely based on the willingness
of the workers to pass through it rather
than face capture device self-destructed
before a thorough analysis could be made
several apparent instances of scp-2099-b
were still found in the warehouse a
brochure bearing the likeness of a
Hispanic man in a lab coat promised
immension is
other locations traced to V2 Enterprises
were found empty
response have I been to Mexico recently
let me see
let me see no not since my grandmother
died clearly we're dealing with an
imposter deal only with the original
Professor V except no imitations or
substitutions
location junkyard in Boise Idaho
prompting statement from
scp-2099-a I did visit one of my
customers once in Iowa I think wait let
me check my notes I tell a lie it was
actually Idaho I always get them
confused would you like to meet her I'm
sure she'd be glad of the company
recovery the field team entered after
hours eventually finding a structure
built under a pile of old automobiles
inside was an apparent residence which
did not appear to have been Disturbed
for some time books of Star Charts
astronomy texts and several Works known
to have been linked to the Serpent's
hand were found inside also inside was
an example of
scp-2099-b labeled valdaport
XT it was not functional at the time of
recovery
response not there anymore well
hopefully she got where she was going or
somewhere anyway
we all want to be somewhere don't we I
know I do
location office in a business park in
London 14th attempted match on partial
address found in third location
prompting statement from scp-2099-a
none
recovery the field team found a surgery
Suite unused since at least the late 80s
several files were found describing
medical experiments carried out two of
the final entries described the
autopsies of a pair of American transfer
students with the initials JV both of
whose descriptions match Jeremy Valdez
all files and reports are signed em
response sorry doesn't ring a bell I
mean I'm not exactly myself anymore but
I'm hardly dead I'm sure I'd know it if
I were I'd have made a note
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Big sip
oh crop guy
cake knock
the Morrigan
Rowan O'Brien
braided Peach
Dean dingus
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
cignar
your local Foundation agent
Lost Boy
and James Saba
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you